Is this an I have a answer but I know if
it's a good one. The objection of John
5:26
that the reason why the father gave
Jesus life in himself is because Jesus
is eternally begotten of the father.
>> Yes. So the giving is doesn't mean it
took place in a moment in time.
>> Okay.
>> Right.
>> The giving isn't meaning that he didn't
have it and then was given to it. This
is simply the way that the Lord would
have to speak because let me explain
what he's saying. I've done sessions on
this guys. Let me show you where to find
it. This is an objection brought up by
semi-arans, full-blooded Arians and
Unitarians. John 5:26.
John 5:26 just put in. So guys, remind
me and pray for me. I got to do two
playlists. I'm going to do a playlist
Islamic Dilemma and then I got to do one
in John 5:26. John 5:26 right here.
There it is. And you pray for me, Dave,
today. I don't eat. Stay on my
intermittent fasting, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Because I don't look like Sil. He's
angry person.
>> John 5:26. Let's go through the answer
what he's saying here.
>> Right here. You just put in John 5:26 in
my search engine and go through the
articles. You see it?
>> Yeah.
>> Just check it out. What's the objection,
guys? Here's the objection. Let's hear
this. This is a good question you got to
learn because Greg Stafford used the
Here's the objection. Truly, truly, I
say to you, an hour is coming, and now
is, when the dead will hear the voice of
the son of God, and those who hear will
live. For just as the father is life in
himself, even so he gave to the son also
to have life in himself. So, what's the
objection? Do make sure to watch my
series referring to Greg Stafford on
this. If Jesus is God, how is it the
father gave him life in himself?
You understand what they're trying to
show the objection? You guys are not
bored, right? You can go for another 20
minutes because I got like two more
people.
If Jesus is God, then why is it the
father gave him life in himself? Well,
number one,
it doesn't mean God gave Jesus life. I
want you to understand how to refute
this. Whatever it means for Jesus to
have life in himself and that life that
he has in himself was granted to him by
the father, it doesn't mean God gave him
life, meaning that he didn't exist. This
is what they're trying to prove to you.
And I'm going to show you how to refute
that. Even if I argue with them and
agree with them, all right, at some
point in time, the father gave Jesus
life in himself, but that doesn't mean
he gave him life, that he didn't exist.
How do I know? Because I'm going to show
you something. You guys pay attention to
this. This is the burial of this
argument. You go to John 6:53. The Greek
is virtually identical.
John 653. I want you to see what do I
mean it's virtually identical.
So Jesus said to them, now watch Dave,
you're going to you're going to amuse me
and you're going to engage me. So I want
you to catch it. Jesus said to them,
>> "Truly, truly I say to you, unless you
eat the flesh of the son of man and
drink his blood, you have no life in
yourselves." It's the same expression.
>> Yeah.
>> Have no life in yourselves. Now guys,
can I ask everyone a question? David,
I'm going to ask you a question. Pay
attention.
The people he's speaking to, they didn't
have life in themselves because he
hadn't given them their flesh. But
weren't they still alive and conscious?
>> Yes.
>> So, one more time. You got it. One more
time. He's telling these people, "You're
going to have to eat my flesh and drink
my blood." They haven't done it because
until you do, you're not going to have
life in yourself.
But he's talking to people who are who
are already alive, who are already
conscious, who already exist. So having
life in yourself cannot mean that you go
from non-existence into existence
because they already exist even though
they don't have this life in themselves.
So that doesn't prove God gave Jesus
life that he brought them into being. It
ain't going to work,
>> right?
>> Yeah. It's not going to work.
>> Because were these people alive?
>> Yes.
>> That he's talking to, were they
conscious?
>> Yes.
>> Did they have existence?
>> Even though they didn't have life in
themselves?
>> Yes.
>> So even if God gave Jesus life in
himself, that doesn't mean he didn't
exist until he was given that life. So
what does it mean for them to have life
in themselves? Well, let's see.
It means until you eat the flesh and
drink the blood of the son of man, you
will not have everlasting life.
All right. Here. He who eats my flesh
and drinks my blood has eternal life.
And I will raise him up at the last day.
So they will not live forever
in glorified immortal bodies and will
not live forever in moral and
corruption. They already are alive. They
already have existence. But they won't
have this kind of life.
You see?
>> Yeah.
>> Then what does it mean? The father gave
the son life in himself. The answer is
right here, brother. Here it is. Note,
it doesn't mean, let me repeat. It
doesn't mean
one more time that the father gave the
son life. So that the son did not exist
until the father gave him life and cause
him to exist. How do I know it doesn't
mean that? Let's see if you're
listening. Rumble everyone else. Let's
see if you're listening. Because he
explains to you what it means for him to
have life in himself. Right here. Truly,
truly, I say to you, an hour is coming,
and now is, when the dead will hear the
voice of the Son of God, and those who
hear will live. Now, he explains, how is
it,
that he's able to make people alive
spiritually and physically? Notice he's
saying, the hour has come, it now is,
when they will hear the voice of God,
and they will live.
Why is it that he's able to make them
alive? For
just as the father has life in himself,
even so he gave through the son to have
life in himself. That's the the reason
my father has life in himself. What does
that mean? My father because he has
life, he's able to give life to others.
Similarly, because I have life in
myself, that's why I'm able to make
others alive.
>> You understand what the meaning is?
>> Yeah.
>> The meaning is that the father has
granted the son to be able to give life
to others.
It doesn't say the father gave the son
life and caused them to exist. That's
not the meaning.
Did everyone get this or no one got it?
>> Yeah, I got it.
>> Got it.
>> So that's number one. No matter how you
interpret this text, it does not prove
that Christ came into existence.
That Christ went from non-existence into
existence. Because I just showed you the
same words. Life in himself is used of
those who are standing before him.
Notice they're alive. They are
conscious. They're alert. They have
existence. And yet they don't have life
in themselves.
So Jesus having life in himself doesn't
mean until he had it, he didn't exist.
That's a butchering of the words. So
what does it mean he has life in
himself? Meaning the father authorized
the son to be able to give life to
others. That's all it means.
Right? So now the question comes down to
did the son always have this ability?
Has the son always been able
to give life? Yes.
Now I'm going to show you that according
to our friend when I don't want to
insult anymore because I know he watches
me because he asked for prayers. Pray
for pristine faith. God have mercy on
him and heal him of his condition and
heal the family and it comes to the
fullness of the truth. No more
demonizing him because he reached out to
me and I want to show him love. He likes
to argue for a different punctuation
that he thinks proves that Christ was
given existence. Nonetheless, when we go
to John one
2 to four, pay attention. Since when has
the son?
Since when did the son have
life in himself? Pay attention, guys.
Ready? If we follow the prologue,
watch here.
John 1 2:4.
He was in the beginning with God.
Beginning when? The beginning of
creation. Already when creation came
into being, he was already there. How do
I know? All things came into being
through him. And apart from him, nothing
came into being that has come into
being. In him was life and the life was
the light of man. Now watch. It says he
was already there when the beginning
came to be. He was there before all
things were created. In fact, all things
were created through him. And he already
had life in himself. So since when did
Jesus have life in himself?
>> Since before creation.
>> So that means he's always had it, right?
>> Yes.
>> Eternally, right?
>> Yes. So that means when the when he says
the father granted the son to have life
in himself, the granting is not a moment
in time. It's not talking about that the
son at one point didn't have the ability
to give life but then was given that
ability later on. The granting simply
means that this ability that the son
has, he has it in union with the father
because that life that comes to creation
comes from the father through him.
>> Yeah.
>> You understand what it means now?
>> So why does God then then speak in
temporal language like granted? Because
there is no other way he can speak.
Meaning if he's talking to creatures who
are bound to time and space and matter
and as creatures of time we experience
things as they unfold before our eyes.
In what other way can God speak
apart from having to use temporal
language? language that will use
expressions that from our perspective
imply time and moments. Even though
God is not bound to creation the way we
are
and yet for him to communicate to us on
our level, he has to humble himself and
use our language and our expressions,
expressions that to us in our experience
imply moments unfolding but doesn't
necessarily apply to God.
How in what other way could God speak?
He can't speak in any other way.
>> That's right. But now there is a
punctuation difference. Let's see if
that punctuation will change the meaning
of this text. So far, you with me, guys,
or you're asleep.
>> Did everyone understand what I said?
Now, David, you got it right.
>> Yeah.
>> Sorry. All right. Punctuation.uation.
All right. Well, you were saying it
alone.
There is another way to punctuate the
Greek and some have capitalized on this
to show you see that proves that Jas
J was created. Let me get you a I did a
session on this anyway. And all these
articles that I wrote was in response to
pristine faith.
All right. Now, Benedict, everyone else
got it right. Understand what I mean?
Now, I did a whole slew of posts on how
John 1 3-4 has been punctuated by the
early Christians to show that none of
them taught that Jesus was created and
came into existence, came into being
because he's the uncreated word logos
who's always existed within God and did
not come into being from nothing.
All right, everyone got it? Now, let's
go right here. John 1 3:4 Jesus Christ
reign. Check out. I'm going to show you
how the New World Translation renders
it. Because after all, they're Aryans,
right?
>> Yes.
>> All right.
This was done for pristine faith. Now,
hopefully he'll accept correction.
Repent. If not, that's between him and
the Lord. Here it is. New World
Translation. Even the Jehovah's
Witnesses don't translate it the way he
wants it to be translated.
Let me see.
Here you go. Here it is. Here's a
different way of punctuating the Greek.
All things came into existence through
him and apart from him, not even one
thing came into existence. What has come
into existence by means of him was life.
You understand?
>> Yeah.
>> Even they don't translate it to mean
that the son came into existence, that
he was made alive.
They even correctly understand that if
you punctuate the Greek differently like
some early Christians, it means that the
life that the creation possesses,
the life that the creation enjoys, the
life given to creation came by means of
him. He is the one that gave the things
that exist their life.
But for him to be able to give the
creation that came into being by him
life, that means he already had the
ability to give life before they came
into being, right?
>> Yes.
>> So how does that prove Arianism?
>> It doesn't.
>> So yes, your answer is correct. It's the
eternal beginning of the sun. Father's
the source of all that the spirit and
the son possess. But they've possessed
it always because they've always been
united with one another.